Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie.
So Deadpool is having some fun with Batman v Superman, I thought it was time for a new video.
They've released an official synopsis in the UK and they're saying that the actual run time of the UK print of the movie is going to be longer than in other places.
So let's break this down.
So here's the actual synopsis for the film, it just, it spells out a couple things that you probably already picked up from the trailers, but here we go;
"Following his titanic struggle against General Zod, Metropolis has been razed to the ground and Superman is the most controversial figure in the world.
While for many he still is an emblem of hope, a growing number of people consider him a threat to humanity, seeking justice for the chaos that he has brought to the Earth.
As far as Bruce Wayne is concerned, Superman is clearly a danger to society. He fears for the future of the world with such a reckless power left ungoverned,
so he dons his mask and cape to right Superman's wrongs. The rivalry between them is furious, fuelled by bitterness and vengeance,
and nothing can dissuade them from waging this war. However, a new dark threat arises in the form of a third man:
one who has a power greater than either of them to endanger the world and cause total destruction."
So the funny thing about that synopsis is that it sounds mysteriously close to Captain America: Civil War.
One superhero worried about other powers running around ungoverned, a third power rising up that's a danger to both potentially.
To be fair, Black Panther's more of a neutral figure than a danger because he was part of the Avengers so they'll be team-mates eventually.
But I just love how, like, collectively comic book movies are shifting the paradigm.
Think back to Marvel Phase One with all the Avengers' first movies, like the first Thor movie, the first Iron Man movie
and then the Man of Steel movie, all about a hero rising up, their big origin story.
Now, on both Marvel and DC sides, we're in this post-war period where it's like what do the people left living in the ashes do about it?
Like how do they deal with these superheroes given all the destruction that's happened?
You know, even though a bunch of heroes try to do good things, there's a lot of collateral damage.
So in Batman v Superman, that's where Batman puts the cape back on. Because it looks like he put it down after Robin was killed.
I think that's what they're implying by the trailer.
But there is a rumour that Zack Snyder, like if you ever watched the Watchmen movie, they did a flashback to the original Watchmen team, the classic Watchmen team
before they showed the modern day stuff. The rumour is that Zack Synder will have a sequence like that before Batman v Superman
where it shows Batman before he hung up the cape and cowl.
Now he is gonna be in the Suicide Squad movie, so they will deal with some of the Joker Batman rivalry
but it's a little fuzzy as to when that happens in the timeline.
I've heard that the events of that movie are supposed to happen before Batman v Superman.
And it is kind of an origin story for Harley Quinn and the Suicide Squad in general so it makes sense that they would already exist in the Batman v Superman world,
so logically I guess it would take place before that.
But hopefully they'll clarify that after Batman v Superman comes out where they're like, "Oh yeah, Suicide Squad definitely happening before Batman v Superman in the timeline."
Zack Snyder also had a couple comments about Justice League, only that they're working on it right now
and that there's gonna be an even bigger villain. He didn't say what the villain's gonna be, I mean obviously they're not gonna spoil it that early.
But odds are if they keep it terrestrial, like if they keep it on Earth, they don't include any cosmic villains like Darkseid or the New Gods or anybody from Apokalips,
it'll be something like Braniac, like if they're gonna twist the Doomsday origin story, and he's gonna be Frankenstein Lex Luthor's monster,
then it totally makes sense that they would have Braniac arise from Kryptonian technology that Luthor Corp tries to use.
It does sound a little bit more realistic, and they kinda did something similar in Avengers: Age of Ultron.
You know, technically Tony Stark wasn't immediately responsible for the creation of Ultron; it was really the Mind Gem that created Ultron
based on a combination of Chitauri code, along with J.A.R.V.I.S.
So I guess I could see a scenario where Braniac arises from Kryptonian technology that Luthor tries to use and meld with his own code and just goes crazy.
The problem with Justice Legaue stories and stories where you use Superman - you use these big godlike figures - is that you have to give them convincing villains.
And it does make sense that they would have trouble fighting an AI just because you can't punch an AI out of existence.
If you haven't been reading any post-Convergence Superman titles, they de-powered him big time, just to give him some more relatable problems.
Although technically he's more at like Golden Age power levels, like leap tall buildings in a single bound Superman.
But I know a lot of you guys have been asking about the rumoured review of Batman v Superman that's on Reddit.
I generally try to avoid stuff like that, and most of the people I know that have at least seen older copies of the script,
say that there's a lot of stuff in that review that's nowhere in the movie. So it's a bit dubious, so take it with a grain of salt; it might be true, but I don't think that it is.
And the other really big controversial thing you may have just heard is that Daredevil season 2 might end up dropping the same weekend as Batman v Superman.
Like that same Friday. The movie's coming out March 25th. Now Netflix are the people that controls when Daredevil season 2 drops.
They've pretty much finished the season, they're probably doing some final touches on it but for the most part Daredevil season 2's good to go.
Marvel does not decide when that airs; Netflix is the one that owns the series. Marvel probably has some influence when that happens,
they're probably like, "Okay, we think you should drop it near Captain America: Civil War or near these other movies," but ultimately Netflix is the one that decides when Daredevil season 2 comes.
So the implication is that, it's not that Netflix wants to hurt Batman v Superman the movie, it's just that they're trying to be disruptors.
Like, "Hey look, we have this awesome thing that you can watch as much of as you want any time and it's all available right now."
Now March 25th is a long way off, so I have a feeling somebody in Warner Bros.'s office is probably placing ten or fifteen calls to someone in Netflix's office,
saying, "WTF, can you move the premier date by at least a week?"
So I'll be super surprised if Daredevil season 2 still ends up dropping on the same day as Batman v Superman.
Now they'll definitely overlap a little bit, there's no doubt about that, but I just feel like Netflix would back off doing something quite so dick as
releasing a giant series on the same day as another studio's giant tentpole movie.
Let me know in the comments, though; do you actually think that Netflix is still going to release Daredevil season 2 the same day Batman v Superman comes out?
Or do you think that they'll move it a little bit?
If you remember, Batman v Superman was originally supposed to drop around the same time Captain America: Civil War was gonna drop
but then Warner Bros. wisely just chose to avoid that, move the movie up to March so they're nowhere near each other.
Competition's totally healthy, but I actually think it would hurt both movies if they were to come out at the same time
because there's always gonna be a bunch of people that only have money to see one of those movies.
Now of course me, a lot of you guys, would probably go broke trying to see both movies, but there's just like a certain percentage of the population,
probably most people, that would only have time and money to see one of those movies.
So the smart business decision on both of their parts is to just space them out a little bit.
But in related free news, there is a whole bunch of TV coming at the end of the month.
So we have Legends of Tomorrow, Arrow, The Flash coming back. Agent Carter season 2. There's even a couple shows dropping tonight
I'm probably not gonna do videos for like Shannara Chronicles, I might do a premier video. Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
And I do have some new Star Wars and some new Legends of Tomorrow, I dunno which order those videos are gonna post.
You can follow me on Twitter and Facebook for updates on that stuff.
So while you guys wait for everything to finish posting, you can click here for all my Batman v Superman videos
and you can click here for my Deadpool video from last night.
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody, let's high five, I'll see you guys tonight.